This episode is brought to you by our supporters
on Patreon.
This series could not exist without the support
of our amazing Patreon patrons.
So, we want to start this one out by saying
a big thank you to those of you who have chosen
to support us.
If you’d like to join our community of Patreon
supporters, you can do so by going to Patreon.com/JourneytoMicro.
For just $2 a month, you can support this
channel and get access to our patron-only
Discord where other viewers of the channel
discuss not only our videos, but also their
own microscopy.
On top of that, you’ll also get a monthly,
hour-long video of some of our uncut footage.
And if you want to bump up your support to
$8 a month, you’ll still get access to all
that stuff, but also you’ll get weekly hi-res
wallpapers of your favorite microbes, and
your name will be added to the list of supporters
that we show at the end of every video.
If you’d like to check it out, you can sign
up at Patreon at Patreon.com/JourneytoMicro.
Do microbes ever feel fear?
Or concern?
Or trepidation?
While they can’t of course tell us, they probably
don’t–
at least not in ways that we could understand.
But we can tell that they definitely experience
stress.
Now, that stress is not  terribly similar to
what we experience when tax season rolls around
or a traffic jam makes you late for an important
meeting.
The microbial world is mercifully free of
such troubles.
But at its core, what microbes experience
is stress nonetheless -
the recognition of, and response to, less-than-ideal
circumstances.
And when you think about it, of course the
microcosmos, can be a very stressful place -
from shifts in food availability, to sudden
temperature swings, to changes in pH that
can begin picking apart a microbe molecule
by molecule.
All in all, there’s a lot going on that
can get in the way of microbes
living their best lives.
So maybe it is no surprise that, naturally,
stressed microbes are everywhere.
Like a bear going into hibernation through
a frigid winter, this tardigrade, also known
as a water bear, has seemingly given up trying
to face the stresses of the world.
Instead, it is lying motionless in a state
of reduced metabolic activity, almost as if
it is simply waiting for all of its problems
to disappear.
It has formed a durable and protective cyst,
and it will stay in there until more favorable
conditions arise.
And it can stay encysted like this for months,
to be woken up by a change in seasons, perhaps.
Microbes from all domains of life have evolved
similar abilities to outlast those trying times.
And they do this by entering extended periods
of reduced metabolic activity, or dormancy.
Because, while microbes can be found everywhere
you point your microscope, that doesn't mean
they can thrive just anywhere.
Each species has its own preferences when
it comes to habitat, its own comfort zone
that is specific to its biology and way of
life.
Holophyra ciliates, for example, prefer non-acidic
habitats that have plenty of dissolved oxygen.
If these ciliates find themselves in a more
stressful acidic environment, they, too, form
cysts and sit tight, waiting for the world
to change.
If they’re lucky, that change might arrive
in the form of heavy rains that increase the
pH of those puddles and pools that their cysts
lie dormant in.
Sensing a more hospitable habitat, they re-awaken,
face the day, and go about their ciliate business.
Now cysts are not the only way members of the
microcosmos can enter the liminal boundary
between life and death, though.
These bacteria have found another way to cope.
The brighter pockets at their tips are the
first stages of their last resort to stress.
Maybe it’s a lack of nutrients in the sample,
maybe the pH levels don't suit them.
Whatever it is that’s left them distressed,
their coping mechanism is unfolding.
They’re each building a cellular bunker,
a spore, which we can see forming here.
Their DNA and essential cellular machinery
will be almost completely dehydrated and tightly
packaged inside the spore’s thick envelope.
Eventually, the spore will abandon the cell
altogether, jettisoning like an escape pod
as the mother cell undergoes a self-destruct
sequence.
In their spore form, with their metabolism
at minimum possible levels, they can last
for decades or even centuries, protected from
the harshest of conditions, biding their time.
But until then, they are part of the
ecosystem’s microbial seed bank -
the repository of dormant microorganisms too
stressed out by local conditions to fully
live their lives, but also too stubborn to
die.
Seed banks are a big deal in the microscosmos.
They allow species to enter cold storage when
times are tough.
In that seed bank, species have tapped out
of the stressful game of life or death.
They’ve found a temporary third option.
And when they awaken, whole microbial ecosystems
can simply pick back up where they left off.
You can wake up a seedbank yourself and watch
it happen at home.
All you need is some food and, of course,
a microscope.
If you soak the vegetables and herbs destined
for your next meal in water overnight and
check the water under your microscope the
next day, you are pretty much guaranteed
to spot some colpodids swimming around.
You have just enticed them
out of the seed bank –
by providing them with a welcomingly wet habitat,
you triggered them to ‘excyst’.
Not to exist, ‘ex-cyst’.
Colpodid ciliates can be found in soils around
the world and they will often hitch a ride
on the surfaces of your food.
Now, do not lose any sleep over the idea that
you are exposed to and are ingesting dormant
microbes throughout your day.
That is just part and parcel of life on this
planet I promise, like you consume them just
breathing- it's just one of many of the bridges
between us and the microcosmos.
Encysted colpodids are not dangerous, they’re
just sleepy stowaways, making the trip from
the soil, to the surface of a tomato, and
then, into your mouth.
James, our master of microscopes, often tries
a few different tricks to coax stressed out
microbes back into excystence.
And using different chemical cues, he can
activate the dormant cysts and spores
of different organisms.
If he wants to awaken the seedbanks of microbes
that have a particular love of sulfur, for
example, he might add the yolk of a cooked
egg to the sample.
For others, the wake up call comes in the
form of fertilizer, which provides nitrogen
and phosphorus.
This stage that we’re looking down at right
now can host an endless combination of casts
performing an endless number of plays, it
all comes down to direction.
It seems wherever you look in the microcosmos,
microbes enduring stressful conditions can
be found, suspended in a twilight zone between
life and death, each species sitting, waiting,
holding out hope for their own version of
paradise to appear.
Thank you for coming on this journey with us as
we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
And thank you again to our amazing supporters
over at Patreon.com/JourneytoMicro.
You’ll be seeing some of their names on
the screen pretty soon, look there they are.
Like I said at the beginning of the episode,
we could not do this show without your support,
so we want to thank each and every one of
you who have supported this channel over the
last almost 4 years that we
have been doing it.
I am so happy to have been able to be a part
of the creation of this show and thank you
to everybody who is or ever has been or ever
might be a patron.
You can check it out at Patreon.com/JourneytoMicro.
Thank you so much.
If you want to see more from our master of
microscopes, James Weiss, you can check out
Jam and Germs on Instagram.
And if you want to see more from us, there's
probably a subscribe button somewhere nearby.